und jetzt reden wir endlich mal über das
vergessene deutsche thema über
datenschutz und zwar in der medizin
gesundheitsminister jens spahn will
unsere patientenakten der forschung zur
verfügung stellen tja also unsere ist
gelogen ja ich kann sie beruhigen es
geht natürlich nur um die daten von
kassenpatienten das ja klar ja und die
können wohl auch nicht widersprechen
liebes kassen gesindel seid nicht
traurig denn ihr könnt uns auf diesem
weg vertrauen und gerade bei
gesundheitsdaten braucht es viel
vertrauen
wer war nicht schlecht wie jetzt du
natürlich werden die daten für die
forschung pseudonymisiert aber gelernte
hacker sagen sowas kann man ratz fatz
rückgängig machen und dann heißt es jede
zelle meines körpers online ja die
digitale krankenakte ist ja genau wie
die gesundheitskarte an sich nur gute
idee nicht verkehrt aber dann sollen
diese sensiblen daten auch bitte sicher
sein
deutschlands niedergelassene ärzte die
praxen müssen sich an den großen daten
topf anschließen oder sie bekommen
weniger geld werden bestraft leider hat
der staat sie aber in sachen
it-sicherheit allein gelassen und so ist
letzten sommer dieses märchen passiert
nach recherchen des bayerischen
rundfunks waren bundesweit rund 13.000
medizinische datensätze vorübergehend
abrufbar
in einer praxis in ingolstadt betraf die
sicherheitslücke über 7000 patienten ja
ingolstadt zum glück mich in deutschland
aber trotzdem
schlimm schlimm ist es ärgerlich
demnächst im kino james bond hektar und
der staat schiebt die verantwortung für
die datensicherheit einfach auf die
ärzte natürlich hat die digitale medizin
das wollen wir nicht verleugnen auch
vorteile
stichwort online sprechstunde überlegen
sie mal da muss die ärztin den patienten
gar nicht mehr persönlich treffen und
kann seine gammeligen morgen per handy
untersuchen das ist viel hygienischer
sohn
die happy müssen da erst die proktologie
sein oder wirklich früher
wir erinnern uns früher haben gestresste
mediziner immer gesagt leute ich kann
mir nicht vier teilen ich kann nicht an
zwei orten gleichzeitig sein
heute geht das problemlos da kommt die
frau dr als ipad angerollt patientin
caroline hat vor drei tagen entbunden
was gerade war kein sketch meine damen
und herren
ja ich finde es schade dass gebären noch
nicht digital geht dann könnte man sich
als mutter das baby einfach runterladen
das wäre viel besser wirklich wir
erleben gerade die einsteller entstehung
einer völlig neuen welt in der medizin
ja völlig neue möglichkeiten mit völlig
neuen witzen meiner mutter ja es ist ja
so es ist ja so immer mehr maschinen
operieren und beraten heutzutage
patienten und selbst die gute alte tante
zdf hat inzwischen reagiert mit dieser
serie jetzt im zdf deutschlands erste
digitale arzt serie doctor clowns
aus leidenschaft eine arzt software wie
immer die richtigen worte findet hier
auf dem röntgenbild sehen wie ihre
leberzirrhose in super 4k auflösung ich
schätze sie haben noch etwa zwölf
stunden zu leben
sorry möchten sie dieses traurige
ereignis mit all ihren facebook freunden
teilen
nein um sie aufzuheitern verschreibe ich
ihnen dieses süße katzen video doktor
klaut er sammelt die daten und bricht
die herzen dokter klar sie haben so
einen großen speicher kommt die app der
die frauen vertrauen
[Applaus]
darf mitfahren
ja
und sie ahnen es auch unsere
versicherung haben den wert der daten
längst für sich entdeckt wer zum
beispiel eine
berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung bei der
generali abschließt kann ein so
genanntes vitality mitglied werden dazu
muss man der versicherung erlauben die
eigene lebensweise und fitness ein wenig
zu überwachen dafür gibt es dann rabatt
auf die prämie oder irgendwelche
gutscheine heißt wer gesund lebt wird
also endlich belohnt
gibt es wirklich noch ist so etwas
freiwillig aber meine wo das hinführt
ist ja völlig klar
hallo ich find's super dass meine
versicherung mir helfen wird gesünder zu
leben
dafür lasse ich mich auch gerne
überwachen deshalb habe ich auch den
stasi tarif gebucht wie das geht ganz
einfach diese fitness am ende hier die
sammeln ständig daten von ich muss
weiterlaufen
und wer zusätzlich den stasi tarifplus
buch der krieg sogar seine eigenen
gesundheitscoach rund um die uhr hilft
mit der stasi tarif mein leben gesünder
zu gestalten
fernsehen zum beispiel gibt - und den
stasi tarif würde ich idiot
wahrscheinlich immer noch rotwein
trinken und nicht diesen leckeren
rhabarber auch smoothie meine stasi app
erkennt sogar ob potentielle
sexualpartnerinnen gesund und ob ihre
brüste echt sind
der stasi tarife meine beste idee war
aber natürlich heißt das nicht dass ich
mich nicht ab und zu auch mal was grund
vernünftiges können
den stand sieht er ihr lebt gesund und
wir bringen die stimmen
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag überall lassen die
ihre dreggsagg michl liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt slx ein beschissenes ab
[Musik]